If you guys see that, I just
saw a commercial, um, uh,
for Kentucky Fried Chicken where the
parents are all excited because the two
bratty kids won't sit
still at the dinner table,
put the got 'em this fucking
chicken and they're feeding it too.
And they basically very subtly saying
that there's drugs in this chicken that
will make your spastic children chill
the fuck out and spastic. I mean like,
you know, not, not the way they
mean it over there in Great Britain,
you can't say that on the comedy or
you can say it in a comedy club over in
Scotland, but you'll have a rough,
you'll have a rough go of it if you
say the kid was spastic over there,
that means like severely
mentally challenged over here.
It just means you're not
going to get laid to you're 26
[inaudible]
when you were in Grad school looking
over a fucking cadaver, right?
With some other fucking
nerve narrowed. Right.
And you're just sitting
there going, you know,
the ankle bones connected
to the knee bone. Right?
Has any of this made any sense? What
shouldn't? It's fucking Sunday night.
And I am spent and I got a whole
bunch of Shit I have to do tomorrow,
so I got to do it tonight.
All right, I'm off my game.
All right. You,
you cleanse your liver and like
42 43 days or something like that.
Every drunk I knows has told me that
every drunk I know that does not have a
medical degree has told me
that if you go 42 43 days,
you will cleanse your liver at least to
the booze. You know? Now if you fucking,
you start doing blow or a, you know,
eating a bunch of trans fat fucking
food or feeding your kids Kentucky Fried
fucking chicken, Jesus Christ.
What happened to parents that you got
drug your kids to keep them under control.
You know, you know what it is.
Kids don't respect their parents,
they respect them, but they don't
respect like, oh my God, this,
this person could ring my neck,
could pick me up by my hair.
Right. Could grab a paddle
and fucking, you know,
mostly hit my ass,
but also kinda hit my lower back
because I'm squirming right.
That doesn't exist anymore. So now
these kids is so fucking out of control,
these people have to go down and
Kentucky Fried Chicken. Okay.
And I, I,
I use the term chicken very loosely
to go down and whatever that is,
that's in that bucket. Okay?
It doesn't have a beak.
It doesn't have feet. If
it's fucking, you know,
chest, his breast is sticking out
like the cast on fucking uh, what was,
what was that show with the Italians?
They're on New Jersey shore. Jersey shore.
Right. My world. That's
not a fucking chicken.
You know,
you want the chicken that looked like
Mark McGuire in his rookie season.
You don't want to eat the chicken that
looks like Mark McGuire when he fucking
played for the cardinals. You know?
Do you eat a regular fucking
chicken? First of all,
it's gonna look like a pigeon to you
because you so used to seeing those roided
up ones that they have murderer's row
that you got down there at your fucking
Shaws, right? Your
Vaughn's, you, JC Penney's,
wherever the fuck you buy your
God damn chicken, you go down,
you go down to any one of the
main stream fucking supermarkets.
Okay. And I swear to God, when you get
to the chicken section, okay, if you've,
if you slept for the last 30 years, like
that Van Gundy guy under the bridge,
whatever his fucking name
is, Van Morrison, the hell's
his name, Rip Van Winkle.
Right. That was one of those
people, one of the vans. Um,
if you slept for the last 30
years and you went down, okay.
And they showed you what a chicken
was, you'd be like, ah. You'd be like,
that ain't no chicken. Okay. It's a
God damn Turkey. I know. Fucking die.
No fucking Turkey when I see one. Alright.
I ain't no such thing as
a mad fucking chicken.
Can't be done. No Sir. No Sir.
Get off my property. Okay. I'm,
I'm done with your witchcraft. Okay.
Pass it. Get the fuck Outta here.
Fuck off my property.
Um,
honey, get the gun. Um, yeah,
you would think it was a fucking
Turkey. And the thing is,
is now it's a chicken. And I remember
I watched one of those food inks,
one of those fucking liberal
goddamn things, you know,
talking about flying carpets and electric
roads and all that bullshit somewhere
in there they were talking about, you
know, the food supply and are poison.
It is poisonous poisoning is is. Um,
so I fucking went down to a
farmer's fucking mock yet.
And um, I said, I wanna,
I wanna I want to all I want, I wanna
I want an all natural fucking chicken.
I can't even talk. I'm so tired.
One an all natural chicken.
The guy goes, these are all natural.
And I said, all natural. And he goes,
well, I'm like, come on, where is it?
And he had to walk around the corner
and sitting over there, lonely.
I swear to God,
looking like a dove look like in
somebody killed the fucking dog.
He goes right there. That one
right there is 100%, all natural.
Nothing's wrong with it. And
I was like, I was like, what?
That's what a chicken
supposed to look like.
And he raised his eyebrows and he,
he kind of put his lips together so
they were a straight line and then he
nodded, you know, that look
that people do like, like, yeah,
I'm in the Matrix. I realize
I'm in the Matrix, but you know,
I knocked the bitch up so I gotta be
selling these roided up chickens now.
Um, anyways, anyway, what
the I'm talking about.
So basically that's what these people
are eating over there. Okay. They are,
they are drugging up. They're kids.
But I can't get mad at him because I
actually did that to Charlie Murphy and
Darnell Rawlings. I've told
this story before. Hey,
I'll tell it against my fucking podcasts.
I actually drug I the exact thing that
they're doing in their Kentucky Fried
Chicken commercial where they're trying
to get their kids to sit still by just
feeding them so full of these fucking
transfats from these roided up beatless
fucking checkins with their Dolly
Parton breasts diseases. Right.
I did that to fucking Darnell and Charlie.
I was hung over and we were taken a car
service from Chicago xannies up to one
of those, whatever the fuck it was.
Saint Charles was a three city run
and one of them was St Charles.
So we're getting in the fucking Limo,
Don L's and ray form
Charlie's and rare form.
They're fucking Gavin and trash and people
and me and everybody and I just don't
want to hear it. I'm like,
I don't want to listen to these fucking
guys running that Goddamn yaps in the
back of this car the whole fucking
way up. I want a nice quiet ride.
This is gonna suck. And I walked outside,
hung over and I walked into
this Chicago where you know,
almost got hit by three
fat people. And um,
I looked up the street and I saw
it, I saw Popeye's and I was like,
oh, thank God.
And I fucking walked in there and I got
all this fucking Popeye's chicken with
biscuits and all of this shit food.
And I brought it back to the
car and as the car pulled up,
they came out and I said, hey guys, I
got itself some, I've got some food.
And they went, oh, that's fucking great.
You know, they were hungry or whatever.
And they started showering that
fucking Popeye's food. And I sat back,
nibbling on drum stick,
and I swear to God, 10 minutes
later they were asleep.
I'm not lying. They were fucking asleep,
snoring the whole way up. And I
was just sitting there loving life,
the whole fucking writeup. And I, you
know what, I admitted to them later.
They thought it was funny, but
that's basically what it is.
They called it the Itis,
that's what they call it when you eat
that shit food and then you have to go to
sleep. They call it the Itis, I guess.
And by they, I mean African Americans,
um, they call it the fucking itis
and that's what they got. They,
and I learned that from Don because I
don't know how that man stayed in shape,
but he had the worst diet.
He's one of those guys who
like you stopped for gas
and he comes out of the gas
station with like one of
those gas station hotdogs
and he would eat it and then he
would immediately fall asleep. And I,
and I would say to Charlie, look
at this guy. Oh he's sleeping.
And Chad be like, yeah
man, he got the itis.
Let me explain that to me and what that
little bit of information it went into
my evil white brain and I drug my two
African American friends way back in the
year 2005. Um, and that's a
little chicken story for you.
What time did you like dad? Everybody.
So that's what the fuck
they're saying right there.
That's what Kentucky Fried
Chicken is allegedly saying.
I guess I have to say a legend.
So their lawyers on retainer don't attack
my fucking pop podcast as far as I can
tell. I'm asking you right now,
a Kentucky Fried Chicken hiding
behind your fucking letters, KFC.
Is that what the fuck you do?
Is that what you're saying?
If you got kids who are not stimulated
enough that they can't even sit down.
If you haven't read yet to have run them
around. You got to tie your kids out.
Open the door. You send them out in
the fucking yard, Gad God's side,
get outside and play. That's what you do.
Like a Goddamn one of
those fucking Irish dogs.
There was bread to have to to herd sheep.
You've gotta let that fucking thing
run around. Run around in circles. Guy,
get out there, take a ball.
You just fucking throw it out in
traffic and let the dog run around.
Dodgy cars that comes in,
it's going to lay down. Okay?
It's not going to jump all over. Company
sticking its cold nose right in there.
Fucking who has. That's what
you gotta do with your kids.
You've got to send them outside, right?
But to catch a Predator and all
these other fucking shows. You know,
all these shows on TV where people
forget their kids are in a car with the
windows rolled up and their kids are
too fucking dumb to roll them down or
they're too weak because they haven't
gone outside and climbed a fucking tree
and they stay in there and their,
their brains get cooked like a boxer.
You know, you know that dog boxes, they
don't, they don't do well in the sun.
Well will neither do fat kids if you
leave the windows rolled up, you know,
and they got those weak arms that all
like the most tedious things they ever did
was take a wrapper off of a
fucking a, an ice cream sandwich.
Right? You can't leave them in the car.
My mother left us in the car all the
fucking time. She would go to school,
she was going to school during the day
trying to further her education and she
left five fucking kids in the car with
the windows rolled up and money for
Burger King. And she would say
to us, just go into the Burger.
That's the only time you were
to leave this car over the left,
over the next three fucking hours when
I'm in class and she would disappear
around the corner after we said absolutely
mom. And she walked away. And uh,
we immediately would get out of the car,
start walking up and down
the streets in Boston.
We'd go into fucking burger king
and we, we'd have some to eat.
Do you know what, what happened nowadays,
if they just saw five fucking dirty
face kids walking up and down,
calm AV Boylston street
going into a burger king,
we're going to cast a fucking nanny.
Someone would have filmed it and
my mother would have been in,
they would have taken us away. No, but,
but they did cause there was no
cameras back then or video tape ones.
I mean there was, but only
people add them on like the news
in a young Steven Spielberg. So we went
in there and we fucking got some food,
climbed bunk cars and fucking
yelled at people and Shit.
Ditto hanging on Platt parking
meters and all that. Hence,
we had the fucking forearm strength to
roll down the windows and none of us ever
had an issue in the
car. And you know what?
I think that's one to grow
on today. You go people,
I'm not saying KFC is food.
I'm not, I'm just kidding.
I'm not saying it's bad
food. Every once in awhile.
Who's kitting home every once a,
we don't go. Don't worry. Great.
If he could just fucking do heroin,
the way you can eat McDonald's,
just like every once in a while he'd
just be like, you know what? Yeah,
let's just fucking tie off.
Not off for the rest of
the fucking day. And like,
the people at work understood it. Hey,
where were you yesterday? Od and yeah,
I've got this black tar
heroin came in, you know,
I hadn't done it like three months
away. I figured fuck it. Oh,
is that what you did? How was
it? I wasn't, you know, like,
like you went to Aruba, you said
hot. I, it was awesome. Fucking,
I don't remember shit.
But you can't, you know,
you get addicted to it.